for me rejection is all about what you
make it mean it's not the rejection it's
the meaning that you subscribe to that
rejection what do you make that mean I'm
not good enough I'm not tall enough I'm
not rich enough as opposed to just one
person like if you're not having sex
like the women you want aren't sleeping
with you I think it's because men just
don't think the juice is worth the
squeeze anymore it's like it's like they
do all this and what do they get on the
other side if mentor on mass they would
change the world that's what men don't
get and I was that most guys have this
unrealistic expectation that they want
every girl to like them no matter how
good you get no matter how high value
you get or anything there's still gonna
be girls who don't like you
how can single men overcome anxiety or
fear of rejection in the dating world
I'll answer that one yeah I literally I
think single men need to actually
partner with other men men like myself
men like yourself and actually learn
from other men and I think they need to
get to the bottom of why that's
happening with they need to do with
their own mindset it's literally because
it's rejection right he said for me
rejection is all about what you make it
mean it's not the rejection it's the
meaning that you're subscribe to that
rejection what do you make that mean I'm
not good enough I'm not tall enough I'm
not rich enough as opposed to just one
person so it really is cultivating an
abundance mindset there are so many
women and great people out there and
once you've got an abundant mindset it's
a bit like I don't know it's like
I don't know it's like I don't know
going to McDonald's and they run out of
your burger do you get upset by it you
go and find another one isn't it right
well you missed the bus you wait for
another one why is it when it comes down
for human beings we feel oh my God I was
rejected it's just okay one person
rejected you now if you're really clever
you might find that why that might be
somewhere to start if you're courageous
enough why did you reject me go and
catch a person you're too short or
you're this or your breath things
whatever find out whatever it is be be
creative they're too short there's
nothing you can do about it so have the
courage to accept things you can't
change that's fine but there are plenty
of very confident charismatic short guys
out there getting women so it's not the
short thing it's it's who you're being
you know what's interesting just being
on social media and like having people
mess it like you know sometimes I do
one-on-ones or sometimes people message
me with like problems or whatever I
found that men are so much more willing
to take feedback than women true where
it's like if a woman if you even imply
it's something with her for the reason
that she's single it's like all hell
breaks loose yeah like I always say this
like if you're single the men you want
don't want you yeah because if the men
you want want to do you'd be with them
yeah and but it's like somehow that's
offensive just like the same way that if
if the girls like if you're not having
sex like the women you want aren't
sleeping with you yeah and it's it's
it's it's it's but the thing is though
even though I think women are much more
likely to do a lot of self-development
work on themselves
from what I've seen a lot of men
self-development is this it's journaling
it's plastic surgery
um it's healing which never includes
actual therapy and if it does it's
short-lived and not consistent I
vehemently
engage in it more men are a lot more
stubbornness in my in terms of coaching
men men tend to be a lot more stubborn
but I think they're a lot more realistic
I think sometimes women can be a lot
more deluded about the actual real world
so taking all this action but it may not
like you said like let me look at myself
men tend to be a lot more stubborn
though about doing that work for
themselves that's the difference I think
if both can tweak it women need to be a
lot more realistic about the world
you're right if you're not getting the
guides you want you need to look at
yourself so it's not the men you need
and it's all it's okay whereas men tend
to do it after the horse is bolted you
know men will do it after say the
marriage is failed or after something's
gone wrong then they start looking
that's what I mean like when when I have
men like ask me about you know whatever
DM me message me and if I give them
advice like they'll come back in a month
or two months later and have actually
improved where it's like women it's just
not the same they I never they do but
look at the stats with men though you
know the statue of men are getting worse
you know one-third of men I think it's
just five and six men are being divorced
I think it's because men just don't
think the juice is worth the squeeze
anymore it's like it's like they do all
this and what do they get on the other
side if mentor on mass they would change
the world that's what men don't get but
men truly demanded a certain level of
behavior they'll change it but men are
falling for the first trap they're
hitting up these girls with likes and
they're telling women they're amazing
actually creating the very well but I'm
saying that they compare started the
women start it because they start with
the Thirsty I don't see a second I don't
sorry to interrupt you by the way I
don't see it as men against women I'm
just saying what kind of world do you
want to create as your action in
alignment with the world you want to
create but my point is that like I think
the women need to start before the man
but what they don't then what are you
gonna do I mean I mean I think like it's
gonna more and more men are gonna be
sexless and I think I think it's
actually going to be in a world where
there's more relationships like that to
be honest
thanks for something no no but
statistically there can only be a few of
you that do yeah the stats won't eat but
that's the point is that more and more
men will be sexless the trend is heading
that way so what does that mean the rest
of us are sharing I think more and more
women will be childless I think 50
probably yeah number 30 will be single
and childless and that's what so I think
if women don't improve that's the future
that we're going to see I wanted to
comment on the the rejection thing so
like what I've found over 10 years of
coaching this stuff now is that most
guys have this unrealistic expectation
that they want every girl to like them
so I tell them like if you were cold
calling in sales or you were knocking
doors it doesn't matter if you're the
best salesman in the world you're going
to encounter people that just tell you
to off or they're going to tell you
I'm not interested and a lot of those
things are outside your control like
there exists girls that have boyfriends
and husbands that don't want to cheat
when you talk to them in the club
there's girls that are in a bad mood
they don't like you for whatever reason
instead of taking that personally and
thinking I suck think okay that one's
just not interested this one probably
will but most men get deflated and then
they bring that negative energy into the
next interaction and then that causes
them to get rejected with a higher
chance it'd be hard not to I mean I
worked in sales I sold copiers and I'm
telling you there's nothing worse than
selling it you just like to sell like a
stand-up ten thousand dollar copy
machine
who wants that and I'm like I I can't
even imagine because when I did that job
it was so soul sucking yeah that I'm
like go getting rejected and that
contributes to the problem right because
the guys have to develop almost like an
emotional resilience yeah yeah you have
to or you just have like this thick skin
and you just know that when you hit
those girls that are interested there's
going to be other girls that are
interested and but a lot of guys will
take it personally I get clients they'll
go up get two or three rejections and
then just give up and they stop
approaching for the night so what's
what's your advice to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection well I
tell them to follow uh the old school
three second rule right so you have less
than three seconds to go in once you see
the attractive girl and then assume it's
going to go well and if it doesn't don't
take it personally and I give them
strategies for how to open properly
right like with direct eye contact
speaking loud enough smiling Etc versus
like coming in Meek and passive and this
and that so I give them chances to give
or give them strategies to give them the
best chances but then also be realistic
about the fact that it's not going to
work out with some girls no matter how
good you get no matter how high value
you get or anything there's still gonna
be girls who don't like you and there's
coaches that are like when you get good
enough there's no more rejections that's
false or you're never gonna get flaked
on a date it's like really people don't
have things come up with their schedule
so these are just part of the game
people have to be able to just deal with
those things and not take it super
personally what about the ladies what's
your advice that to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection I
haven't heard too much from you
okay I want to hear from these three
first I feel like the more that you do
something the more confidence you have
when you do it like rejection is not
always rejection I like the phrase
rejections redirection so it's like just
do it there's a quote I don't know what
it's like it's like confidence is the
amount of times you do something okay or
something like that basically just do it
just try to put yourself out there
what's a good opening line and I want
the guys to say if you think these are
good but a guy should use to a girl I
wonder I want the dating coaches to read
it
oh see I don't know I don't have words
like that I like
him
um I like quina grasses
um
um okay I like gonna guy says Hey excuse
me you're looking really beautiful today
um or say hi um how are you did it like
something like that I don't know I like
I like to be complimented like oh oh do
you need help with I don't know if they
see me doing something oh oh what are
you doing here today I don't know like
nice not like
forward like so the good opening line is
high you look very beautiful today how
are you yeah yeah no no how you look
very beautiful today like
like what's your name like where are you
from like oh do you mind if I could um
good or bad uh it depends on like you
know if he's like kissing your ass or
like supplicator in the dark but if it's
just like a nice comment that's fine
yeah yeah now that you ask me I think
I'm part of the problem that we're
talking about because if a guy was to
move to Miller Street I wouldn't take
him seriously for sure that's the thing
yeah I think I would just assume that he
does that with everyone but he's single
so yeah
he wouldn't say the higher you're
beautiful
okay okay so you think it's cringe you
think it's okay it depends I mean like
those like London digging guys were like
hello I thought you're hot and like that
and they're just doing that like in Mass
right yeah that's why he said it depends
on how you say it that's a nice thing my
opener for 10 years just been I want to
meet you real quick it's like very
direct I wanted to meet you and you say
like when they're like okay yeah yes
that's that's the way but I hope
pedestal oh my God you're beautiful how
many times did she had that no no like
that but like you're putting it on a
kind of level of oh my God you're so
beautiful I'm not used to know because
hey how's it going what's your name
how's it going it depends on the frame
of how it comes across like you don't
want a guy that comes up wow you're like
the most amazing you don't want that
she's like oh I just saw you like I
thought you look really beautiful like
you know what are you doing around here
like what are you doing today I like
that kind of thing
what's your advice to you guys and
what's your opening line My love
language My love language is acts of
service so if it's something very simple
as let me get that for you as he's
opening the doors my knees start to go
weak or even yeah or even at the bars
like like let me get that for you I'm
just like okay all right it's like Jay
Waller he says don't open doors for
girls
I still believe in that um but also with
me I'm very I'm a person that's very
aware and I also know that rejection is
very hard so if a guy does take does
approach me I know it's taken him a lot
to be able to do that so I'm not going
to reject him and be rude and say oh I'm
not interested I'm gonna go with the
flow the conversation and I'll let him
down gently but I think it also what you
were saying that you're the problem it
takes us to be as human beings to be
empathetic as well to understand that
he's still a human he does still have
feelings it has taken a lot for him to
approach you so just be nice yeah for
sure so what do you think of her I like
that because that's quite natural isn't
let me get a dolphin hey where you have
to yeah her name how's it going yeah
I don't know
you cannot be I don't like anything
that's like all like contrived I mean
that's not gonna even happen that often
right like in terms of like situation
depending
I think just starting the conversation
and being direct as long as there's not
like fancy gaming gimmicky stuff then
that's thumbs up for me okay what about
you what's your advice to men what's a
pickup line that you like
have like a specific pickup line but I'd
say be confident not arrogant and be
just be straightforward what's the
difference between confidence and
arrogance well I feel like in the
context
with the context that we're talking
about you don't want to come off as I
know I'm coming to get you and I'm
getting you and I'm I've got you did you
get one do you know what I'm doing
confidence
I think confidence is I don't mind
getting rejected but if you reject me
I'll walk off like a man and I won't oh
you're dead anyway or you know oh that's
the worst of a guy yes mad yeah okay
thing though yeah like for example no
yeah that's that just to use that
happens in sales too right I don't know
if you saw that in sales but I did sales
for a summer to see how it translates to
game and there's like rookies that go up
the door and the guy slams the door on
their face and they're like yelling
stuff at the guy or it's like a veteran
who's like okay that person's not
interested and they don't take it
personally yeah versus like trying to
get even no in the UK guys take it
personally they'll be like oh you're
ugly anyway
but that's young guys really yeah
I did that comment I just like here and
there yeah yeah yeah I know it depends
um so did you have a line or no I don't
have a line but I'd say me personally I
like it when a guy starts off with a
compliment but not an obvious compliment
not anything to do with my face whether
it be something about my style or the
way I carry myself oh so I forget
compliments your style yeah something
like that yeah good or bad
that's good yeah that's cool okay uh
what about you yeah usually like I
started complimenting this style or
something that because like if I'm
approach a person like uh for sure it's
because there's something that I'm
interested in that person I don't know
if they approach you
oh I think you're really cool yeah like
you seemed me really cool what's your
name oh can you talk oh let's think fun
facts okay that's a compliment though
yeah do you like that one yeah I mean as
long as it got like the biggest problem
I've seen is that like a lot of coaches
say like come in and say oh you look
like you like this or like you know just
say really cheesy fancy gimmicky stuff
where they're like using lines or like
you know these these clever pickup lines
or like different stuff like that and
that just has like this air of like this
is a a little tactic that I'm trying to
win you over with yeah like all the
common theme between all the responses
is they want the guy to be like genuine
and actually like showing that he's
interested without hiding it right like
guys that come up and ask you for
directions like it's obvious that they
don't want directions yeah but like you
like lose maybe a little respect because
he's not having the balls to be
straightforward and that's the iron if
you think about it you only get good at
that if you deal with rejection right
because it's almost the emotional
calibration and you have to deal with
the rejection to get that inward that
didn't work well that didn't work with
that type of woman so you have to do it
in order to have the hey how's it going
how are you doing that's the beauty of
rejection what's your line
my line oh
um
yo what's happening
every London guy ever actually is that
what he said pretty much I did I did
yeah yeah I have to own that but also I
want you approached him yeah okay how
what line did you use
it wasn't really a line it was an
ultimatum a little bit if you don't want
me there's lots of men doing she really
played the kind of manipulation with it
we were good friends for a long time
though to be honest I've seen him did
you friend zone him or did she friend
zone you no no one friends only Trevor
when I first saw I was in a relationship
so and then we just became friends we
were doing a lot of the same coaching
and self-development together and then
when I got single she kind of did the
ultimatum if you look you better take me
now because you don't someone else will
want me
you know but for the minute I first saw
it it was just like love at first time
but I wasn't a relationship that's crazy
that's nice
the girl because of her it just didn't
work out well yeah dump her if it was I
thought it was right because
where I met at the contest I met her we
were doing a lot of self-development
training a massive um self-development
country
um uh company and integrity was a very
important thing in terms of the training
we were doing and I had to learn that
because I've come from a culture of just
chatting up girls willy-nilly right but
I still never really believe in cheating
necessarily I'm avoids because my
parents have been married for 60 plus
years I've always believed that monogamy
the rest of it but from an Integrity
point of view I was already in a
relationship so straight away I'm not
gonna even go there I can acknowledge oh
my God she's beautiful that's exactly
the kind of woman I want to be with but
because of my situation I was like I'm
not going anywhere near there and when
it naturally ended and I was single and
we were friends for ages she then made
the move and I was like hell yeah I'm a
threat because for a minute I met you
you were perfect you know Fair woman
yeah I don't know I don't know what to
feel about that I don't know whether to
be like
respect or be like the iris but what if
it had worked out with the girl you're
in a relationship with yeah I've never
got into a relationship with him you'd
have been in love she was an opportunist
yeah
I own my action I've seen that guy and
there's a lot of values that he have the
I value now here's the thing right even
though he was in a relationship I didn't
really interfere at all you were friends
we probably chat once every now and then
now when he was uh not in that
relationship I was not his type anymore
because when he met me I was the perfect
size you know I was perfect look I lost
it I had to work my you know self to be
that person and that's nothing I own who
I am you know I mean I know exactly what
I want and if there is an opportunity of
course I'm gonna go for it you know
there's no shame about it yeah go for
what you want yeah yeah and my dreams
yeah and my advice for guys because I
know that's the question is don't listen
to women they most of the time they
don't know personally I don't know what
I want from a man go and find someone
that inspires you a man that really have
that perfect relationship there's so
many coaches out there coaching you
about relationship but they're not on
one go and find a relationship that
inspires you and get his advice he will
be able to open his heart and share his
advice with you so question for the
women have you ever approached a guy
and have you ever been rejected
no yes yes yeah oh cool okay tell me
tell me about it I've approached but not
been rejected oh you've never been
rejected you have you approached yeah
have you been rejected yeah what
happened
um it's just when I open up and say what
I want from my future and what I like
for example that I want to be married
and I want to have family they tend to
be like you said that immediately yeah
okay yeah okay I'm pretend I'm the guy
not a bar and say oh I want to get
married like on the first date or
something like that yeah on the first
day I'm talking about like approaching a
guy like cold approach oh no no no no
never have you ever cold approached uh I
think I have
at a bar at a club yeah they're always
into it yeah okay what about you have
you ever called approach no no no have
you ever promised
I don't think so no that's interesting
right I would know I don't know I don't
think so no I have yeah
no never yeah
what about you have you ever approached
a guy yeah were you ever rejected yes
really yeah how what do you say
um I remember like once I was like in
the grocery there was this really hot
guy like it was like John like exactly
no she was like my type like this and
then I was like oh my God but I was like
you know it was like civil engineer work
in a site construction so well like
almost like the majority of my time I
wasn't like dressed up I wasn't like
cute it was like with boots like jeans
like you know
and now I could come up to him and he
said oh I'm sorry I'm married and I said
okay
um he's married that's good
and I think like when I was younger too
like I I don't know I think getting
rejected is like part of life yeah
I'm curious from the guys is there a
rejection that was like your worst
rejection that you can think of well
I've called the approach like probably
tens of thousands of times but you know
every now and then there'll be a girl
who just tells you to off or like
tries to insult you personally or
something like that and that that can
hurt sometimes right you get over that
like you just you just learn that's
gonna happen sometimes but especially
for like clients that aren't used to
approaching if they hear something that
early on where the person says like oh
no I don't like you because of this and
this that sticks in their head and they
think every girl thinks that and it can
be like debilitating and I can take them
out of the game I think for me the the
worst approach
um rejections I can remember is when
they don't say anything they pretend
they don't hear you no they look at you
like how dare you even think you have
what it takes to come up to me and I
don't say it's just everything in the
eyes it's saying that and you feel like
some girls friendly don't hear you too
like they just stand there but it'd be
nice if they're pretending they don't
think anybody hurt you
I'm almost insulted that you've come up
to them that happened to me like two
days ago with a girl okay I I just was
complimenting her outfit I was like oh
my gosh that's so cute she just looked
at me no and I know she's I know she
heard me and then she just like kept
like I was sitting at like a table bar
you know what I mean and she just kept
she just like looked the other way okay
then then I go to this other place right
and she's there and then she she starts
talking to me and she's like can you
take my Instagram picture I'm like
I just said
hello again
so I feel you that that was that was why
but that was when I was young now I'm
like I'm so it's it becomes almost like
funny though like in the beginning like
if a girl would ignore I'd be like oh my
God like I'm horrible yeah but now like
if I go to a bar and I'm like okay I
want to meet you real quick and the
girl's like pretend she's in here I'll
be like I know you hear me can I just
talk to her a sec if they're still not
responsive then I'll just walk away you
know I just walk away right away but it
doesn't even register you get to the
point I mean if I was single as well
it's like you just don't care yeah but
it's almost like it's almost like funny
too you're like look at this okay the
chat is saying tell me you didn't take
her picture I did I'm not even going
[Music]
yeah yeah I was like I don't like this
look at that woman that became a man for
a bit wasn't it the story where she
became
suicide on her life the surface they say
yeah which is only a man for a short
time well I don't think most women are
like I don't think we really noticed the
privilege we're given in society just
from being young women where we're like
treated better by people and the first
time this happened to me I am I worked
in a sales job and I was the only girl
in the office and people would always
help me with whatever I wanted you know
what I mean yeah and all the guys around
me would be like oh it's because you're
a girl it's because you're a girl and I
was like no it's because I'm so bubbly
and I work hard
yeah okay yeah and then I found out it
was in fact because I was a girl because
I feel like not even in like a romantic
way but I think that men just have more
of an inclination to like help yeah they
were fun what it's more fun than helping
it go yeah yeah even if it's not like it
also goes the other way though because
then there's also a sense of not taking
women as seriously as well so it flips
doesn't it I've never had like I've
never felt that was an issue to be
honest and I've worked in like
predominantly male dominated Fields I
think it's an advantage not a
disadvantage yeah but I think you've
probably learned how to you know you're
powerful woman so you've learned how to
I'm the same I will always navigate
whatever you know limitations to say
based on Me based as a black man for
instance I don't care yeah some people
don't learn that skill so they actually
internalize no I'm not enough excuse I
think there's zero limitations as a
woman like zero none unless it's like a
string I agree I'm not gonna lie yeah I
feel like the girls that whine about
going to corporate and having a hard
time like I just think it's an excuse
they're just big whiners I don't think
so Pearl I have to say there is there is
a listen there's women do get treated by
compassion people help them out but
there's also the view of like oh women
is it weaker than a man and there's
nothing wrong with that logic like
physically woman is weaker than a man
but if a woman's trying to get some
level of finances or authority she will
definitely get a backlash of like you're
a woman I disagree I think there's quote
there's quotas for women I think women
get put in positions they shouldn't be
in all the time what do you mean like I
feel like women get put in positions
they're actually not qualified for and
they're not the best person for the job
because of quotas and diversity Hunters
yeah some some um
where women or people of color do have
to prove themselves more in order to be
getting taken seriously no so I just
think as for women in my experience I I
don't think there's any disadvantage and
most of the girls I know that complain
about it are just kind of lazy to be
honest I don't agree with you perro I
get you but I don't agree with you given
that I'm with my partner and sometimes I
go for what he's going for I put my
hands up I don't speak as perfect
English and I'm not intelligent as much
as he is but there's a lot of positions
that he gets picked when I don't you
know maybe he's just better he is
unfortunately yes that's right but
there's sometimes when they give him
chances but give me a chance to just
prove that I'm better or maybe I'm equal
in some there is a lot of places that
I'm quite equal but I feel like it's
like a mindset thing like if I if I get
passed up for a job with a dude like I'm
not gonna think it's because of my
gender I'm thinking I'm gonna think it's
because I'm not good enough yeah but
that's what I mean there's two different
things at play one there is and a
disadvantage for some people in society
whether it's based on your race whatever
it might be even height they've showed
studies about that but I think the
second thing is who are you in the face
of that and that's what you're alluding
to yeah so I don't care there are times
of course I mean I've grown up as a
young black boy how many times I've got
stopped by police of course
statistically I knew there was more I
have friends that would walk around with
whatever in their pockets they never get
stopped because I do I get it it's a
reality but my thing is who are you
going to be in the face of it that's the
difference so I recognize that Society
does treat different people differently
that's that's just true but my thing is
I don't do the victim thing because of
it I think that's what you're talking
about you're not a victim in fact I
actually turn on his head because it
happened I'm gonna go even harder that's
it you know I was brought up told you
you're black you're gonna have to work
three times
yeah I'm not gonna complain no why is it
and it's given me an advantage
disadvantage gives you an advantage you
see it with like rappers in that they're
hungry get the way they come from they
mean it when they say get rich or die
trying there are discrimination against
them but it makes them what I don't like
is victim culture but I just I think
that Society openly discriminates
against men way more than women and that
like and I
think there wouldn't be
Otis in these jobs yeah like I think
people want women in leadership
positions because in a lot of companies
they have diversity hires true but
that's quite a recent thing I would say
probably isn't in the last generation I
mean it's been implemented since like
the 60s at least in the U.S since the
60s yeah that's generation or two yeah
but that's I mean I'm 26 so that's two
of two of my lifetimes that's quite a
long time to me
it's the pendulum thing isn't it I think
it's sung too far now it's just I was
like let's get someone diverse in there
even though they're not I mean I think
about I'm bad that I say about our
Chancellor of course an absolute
nightmare I wonder if he was thrust in
that position next thing you know he had
the most terrible him in the prime
minister is trust you know that's an
example I think where people just put
into position because
swinging I actually don't really see it
like women were discriminated against
like ever because I just think that we
had different roles like we could say
that men were discriminated against
because they had to go to war we didn't
have to go I don't think I think Society
was set up differently I don't think
it's discrimination in that so I mean
give an example for instance right if it
wasn't for the fact that men went to war
women would never have been allowed in
these industrial jobs it's not
discrimination it's just a limitation
based on an assumption of your woman you
can't do it strength you know or you're
black you can't do it well I mean I
think when it comes to war like we can't
now but women did women did fill the
positions that men left behind I was
talking about war oh actually we're
going yeah I mean me and you could fight
your even if I'm the strongest woman
you're gonna win
physically yeah I mean there are some
female climbers out there that run rings
around something if women were doing so
well in the military they wouldn't
continually lower the requirements for
them
it's true like they literally had to
lower the requirement for us to become a
seal I think when it's physically like
that but definitely in society there
have been instances where people have
not been given a chance because of an
assumption about what they were capable
of and when they were given that chance
you could see that they excelled I mean
at the time the NBA wasn't full of black
players you know there were times for
instance we've got a friend who's a
black um football agent there was a time
that was unheard of it was a time when
women weren't seen able to run a
football club and yeah I'm just talking
about gender yeah so when my what I was
talking about was when I just don't
think women were ever really
discriminated against I think Society
was different
yeah
I don't know I I think do you find
discrimination what's the definition of
discrimination about like earning
differentials right even the modern days
because of their gender isn't it really
is well I come from a culture when it's
the opposite to the West right now women
do get abused I was about to say these
are the people that I know personally
the man will cheat she can't say any
word and she will get hit and there's no
one's gonna stand for her she goes to
play her parents stay in that marriage
you've got kids and you're not coming
back to us
I'm talking about in the west I don't
know what but that's what I'm saying we
could do different things right but
that's one he says it's been shifted
right so there's a lot of women right
happen because of that because it that
was like 100 years ago here so the woman
stood and raised their voice but it
became quite toxic right now and I think
what's really missing is balance yeah
that's possible yeah there definitely
was a time when women were discriminated
it's happening just along and gender
lines in class lines at the time for
instance working class guys couldn't
vote so there's always been a sense
where power's been concentrated in the
hands of whatever privilege it was and
that the other had to fight for that oh
they can actually that's my point is
like it wasn't it was about like roles
and responsibilities like it wasn't just
open discrimination but I mean it was
but it wasn't like for example like they
always talk about how women couldn't
vote but the majority of women didn't
want to vote like if they asked them
they pulled them and the majority of
women didn't want to vote because it
came with being drafted and so how it's
it's not really discrimination it's
roles and responsibilities where the men
were responsible for protecting or the
women were responsible for staying out
but before women got their suffrage
wasn't it the case that men who were
fighting also didn't didn't have a
chance to vote so the majority of people
didn't have the chance but I don't
remember exactly how it was structured
it's been it's been a bit since I've
looked at it but like I actually because
there was always this narrative that
like women were oppressed and put down
and that's always what I thought until I
found out I started researching the
anti-suffragettes or whatever they were
called and there are basically like
women that were against women voting and
I because I was like why on Earth would
women not want the right to vote and it
turned out it was because it came with
the responsibility because when you
think about it you're voting at least in
the U.S for the commander-in-chief so
that's the person that's in charge of
the army so it kind of makes sense for
you to have some skin in the game but
you don't think that historically women
weren't discriminated against and you
know
forget like even more but you say women
authors had to come out as men in order
to be taken seriously women
photographers had to pretend they were
men in order to be taken seriously
they've been time and time again
instances in in society where women had
to pretend to be men in order to be
taken seriously I mean same with the
first female doctor I believe it was in
France I think had to I think if you had
to pick women by and large being
discriminated against in men by and
large being discriminated against I
would say men were discriminated against
more yeah men and women I'm just because
then it becomes our men have had it
worse than women and it becomes this
battle I'm talking just purely in terms
of you know women discriminate against
and so if men has there ever been
discrimination ever sure but do I do I
think it's like this narrative that by
and large like women had such a horrible
life and were oppressed and all of this
stuff like that yeah no I agree with you
I think that's been fanned by certain
elements of third wave and fourth and
fifth waves of feminism that's true but
definitely historically women have
definitely been discriminated against
and so have many men I really think that
feminism it's all the same wave um I
think it is it and always has been a
hate group
because it started in 1888 in Seneca
Falls New York
um and the first anti-suffragettes they
planned assassinations
um they yeah people don't realize that
yeah people like they weren't this like
peaceful group that people think about
um so yeah I think it's always been the
same movement which is freedom we want
the freedom without the responsibility
and it started with the right to vote
because they wanted the freedom of
voting without the responsibility of
having any skin in the game and I think
it always started with wanting to
destruct the family because if you look
at the anti-suffragettes um which like
if you look at their writings about why
they didn't want to vote they would talk
about how
um this was the beginning of the
destruction of the family because before
then you trusted your husband um you
trusted his leadership and so that it
was in they were right it was the
beginning of the destruction of the
family because the policies that
feminism has
placed and caused has eroded the family
in the west
I probably wouldn't go to that extreme
that it was based on hey I think there
was legitimate
um you know need for women to have some
level of emancipation because at some
point they were the property of the
husbands how they could do whatever they
want with them I mean there are some
things where women couldn't say anything
about it I mean you see in Islamic
cultures now Islamic coach is only a bit
it's pretty much where Victorian culture
was in some instance so I think there
was a genuine need by women to free
themselves and give them the
opportunities to be all they could be in
life I mean I I think I think you could
my argument isn't was it was it needed
or not needed my my argument is it was
always freedom without responsibility at
the expense of man
and so when it starts with the vote it
was the freedom of voting without the
responsibility of going to war so if you
elect someone batshit crazy into Power
who has to deal with that Consequence
the men not the women and I know some
people argue we don't go to war today
which is you know it's a fair argument
but when it started it was freedom
without responsibility at the expense of
men
this is going deep yeah I think it might
be I I tell you I'll tell you why I say
it a little bit I think they've been
pioneering women that have paved the way
for you to have a show like yours that's
that successful and they had to
sacrifice a lot for you to be yeah and I
think legitimately they did it in order
to really have freedom I think even they
would be appalled at how far it's gone
today well and I and I think that's
always what people say like how how do
you have these thoughts when you have a
podcast like yeah of course they benefit
individually but when I when I look at
things as a society do I think that
ultimately that was good those policies
that feminism has passed as a society
you know I can acknowledge I have
individual benefits that benefit me
individually that I don't think have
helped the society by at large yeah no
and I and and for me I will defend to
death you're right to say that and
that's what I love about what you do
people may not agree with everything you
say but I love the fact you say it
because it starts this discourse this
conversation that's going on I do
believe a lot of the movement right now
is causing a lot more harm you know we
need fathers back in the home we've seen
the harm that's done we need a lot more
why are you throwing out the baby with
the buff or there was a lot of
traditions they were great well I was
getting rid of them some women are not
happy well and we don't we act like we
don't need men I mean even the fact that
we have Envy like women getting in vitro
fertilization without without having a
husband it's like you're acting like you
don't need a father to raise a child and
that's not important yeah yeah
absolutely I think we men need women no
man's ever going to say they don't need
women
and I think women need men and I think
that's what I want to see and I think
those are the conversations that we
really need to be having how can we
bring it back together but not go all
the way back to the days where women
don't ever vote it's never going to go
back to that yeah thank God
to go back is to embrace more
Traditional Values yeah that's the only
way because like yeah that's the only
way you need to be more traditional but
but this is the problem I feel like
whenever we have that conversation it's
always about the men being more
traditional I mean the women need to be
more traditional as well which also like
tradition that includes letting your
husband lead you and submit to him what
do you think about like women not going
to college anymore
[Laughter]
there's other careers you can pursue you
don't need unique yeah I think if you're
gonna go uni do one of the stems if
you're going to add 30 40 well 90k or
whatever it might be to stand the United
philosophy make it worth it crazy yeah
no what do you think a lot of people are
doing women not going to UNI anymore
College
um
I I think like personally that they're
never actually gonna go back to like I
think it sounds nice to say let's go
back to these Traditional Values I just
don't see it happening yeah like I just
don't I mean God God I see I see women
sharing less men and men being more
sexless that's what I see but then
that's just outstanded that you want to
set and then what you're not just gonna
compromise I I'm not just gonna
compromise like
you know it's actually I I I'm gonna
change my mind I do think less women
should go to college because all the
degrees are getting are so stupid
with AI too right like it's it's better
like chat gpt4 is better than the
average lawyer doctor programmer wow
artist all that stuff yeah we need to
reevaluate I'm accused of using chat GTP
the other day and I didn't know what it
was and then I looked at I was like
maybe I should it's really good
it's good tool but I don't know I think
do you really think that like what do
you think is going to be the few I know
this is very off topic but what do you
think is the future with chat GTP
um I think it's gonna eliminate
civilization I think it's going to be
extremely negative
um basically the whole idea of the
singularity where there's this
exponential increase of Technology right
now it's able to recursively
self-improve itself without the need for
human intervention and it's getting the
point where it's better than humans
almost everything already like today and
it's only going to continue to increase
exponentially so to me like when
Computing systems are trying to optimize
their power once it's combined with like
3D printing and nanotechnology for
instance it's just the end result seems
like it's going to be there's no place
for humans that's my view and I think
that's right around the corner to be
honest I agree actually yeah because I
was thinking they could even recreate
this podcast yeah yeah
you've seen the girls that you've seen I
see them on Twitter where it's like a
fake picture of the girl like imagine
they could do this podcast but it's fake
they definitely could but I'm sure they
I've seen a video of them uh they
created a music video recreated a music
video with AI and it was a normal music
video wow that they just had redone with
AI you know the film um that'd be fun
you know the film the full it come out
this year or last year they used AI in
that film I was watching it so it is
more realistic than a lot of people
think the movie was like you you
wouldn't say your whistle like creative
like yeah yeah you wouldn't realize
you wouldn't realize
I'm optimistic I think we've had so many
ways of technological information
Innovations where they thought it's
going to be the end of society but we
know it and and we've seem to have done
all right that maybe that's just me I
that's what my dad says yeah I think
we're gonna find a way to live with it
because I said it with everything but
the biggest show now is that you have
all the big uh tech company monopolies
like doing like almost like an arms race
to get the stuff to market the quickest
so there's no ethical or regulatory
measures being imposed and and people
aren't even sure what this stuff can do
they're just building it they're not
even sure like what's going on in the
middle layers and stuff with all these
neural networks and they're not sure of
like the machines like true intentions
and stuff like that I just see us as
machines as well I have like a
philosophy and cognitive Science
Background as well
um but like I really see that there's
going to be this intelligence explosion
like with the next five years probably
in the maximum
um where it's just going to be this
runaway phenomenon and unless you know
this is Elon musk's thoughts but unless
we co-evolve as cyborgs using something
like neurolink or these brain computer
interfaces we're just going to be like
left way behind in terms of capabilities
intelligence capabilities
remember the days when the internet
first came out and I thought oh my God
you know everything and it's gonna be a
nightmare get post out of this saying
um I've got a ramble just in case look
at the internet how wide it is yeah look
how narrow it is what we're allowed to
talk and not talk about who's to say
that chat gbt is going to be legislation
is just going to wipe out all that
capability Italy's already done it it
might get to the point I mean imagine
I've heard Jay-Z raps not done by Jay-Z
yeah done by that and it just gets to
the point that all of this copyright
laws if they'll just throttle it
with capitalism in militaristic
imperatives I don't think there's any
way to stop it realistic do you actually
question or do you believe in capitalism
yeah okay no because I I did um
there is a I had an Uber driver the
other day and it was so interesting he
was from Eastern Europe I can't remember
the country but he used to live in like
a socialist
um country when Russia the USSR yeah
yeah and I'm not a big history so I'm
sorry if I butchered this but he was
saying how it was so much better under
like socialism and I've never heard that
take ever and it was because he felt
like life was like simpler and it was
better without all the technological
advances I agree in so much yeah but we
throw that Roomba we've thrown in we're
throwing out the baby with the bath
water again and again and again and
again in pursuit of this new future that
no one knows where it's going to lead at
least with the past you knew exactly
what was good I think we need to event
reevaluate what's good about it what we
can keep what we can't but some of it
you can't go back to even like
traditional Families my mum never worked
but my dad has six kids but they could
they could afford to to factor in
inflation can you afford to have one
person working nowadays
I wonder if like the powers that be that
own AI will sort of rewrite his history
in a way
you know what I mean because they can
they can all the texts are in the
computers and stuff so they can kind of
rewrite history the way they would want
to if it's like whoever owns the AI
stuff yeah you can pretty much do
anything like Bill Gates went on record
saying that this is the greatest
invention since like the graphical user
interface where they had like computer
programs you know being interfaced with
like Windows basically he said this is
like the next instance of something like
that happening it's really that
transformative it's it's transforming
every industry and it's eliminating a
lot of jobs already yeah it's huge I
mean you wouldn't be able to rewrite
history of written history Because
unless you can rewrite those physical
books but yes I mean that's an argument
for us to start to switch off the
technology a little bit isn't it maybe
that could happen that could actually be
something that happens yeah this is like
where I kind of go back to traditional
like the idea is nice yeah do I see
people using their phones less now some
people aren't checking out though aren't
they you know and you you just never
know I mean did you ever I mean I'm not
going to get too controversial but there
are some things that we discussed now
that 10 years ago you'd say that was
absurd right I'm not gonna go into we
all know this some I've said stuff
that's been discussed today you would
never fought 10 years ago would happen
it is so it's the same 50 years time
people don't voluntarily say right we're
getting rid of all our computers
like the Unabomber that's like what his
agenda was right like he was like a
hybrid educated guy that was saying like
the end result of this like
technological advancement is going to be
like a no need for humans and we have to
stop it but I really don't think it's
realistic in terms of like you know with
militaries in competition with
capitalism
you know if anybody stops they're just
going to lose an advantage against the
other countries
Cameron take a second to read Super Chat